[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est ce que tu sais qu olivia est à fond
sur ton mec ou non tu délires tu dis
n'importe quoi
pénélope action roule une pelle à olivia
qu'elle a fait comment génial car ta
vérité quelles sont tes intentions
envers notre cher olivia il fallait que
je trouve quelqu'un que je puisse
attirer dans cet endroit avec ses amis
j'ai tout de suite su qu olivia serait
une cible facile
je vous ai amené ici parce que ça ne me
dérange pas que des inconnus meurent
pour que je reste en vie aquatique jours
c'est pas qu'un jeu quoi que tu fasses
où que tu ailles il se retrouvera
toujours
ça va ouais ce qui se passe des trucs
super bizarre depuis qu'on est revenu du
mexique
[Musique]
je rigole pas je vois des choses
action ou vérité action
je sais que ça paraît dingue juste un
peu cette charmante jeune femme vient de
me mettre au défi de vous montrer mon
matos déjà vu rien d'impressionnant
carter a été clair tu dis la vérité où
tu meurs tu relève le défi route humeur
site abandonnent la partie
en fait ça me gonfle tumeur
3 ou pas
mais juste des pions
qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors choisis
toujours vérité qui passe son temps à
tromper lucas le cas atteint suis désolé
si tu me touches encore je te pète la
main c'est clair mérité ça ne fonctionne
pas comme ça lui est la main d'olivia
t'as pas le choix j'ai vraiment la haine
contre toi mais il est hors de question
que je te pète la main je crois que tu
m'as pas avoir le choix
vas-y fais-le sais je vais trop fort
pour nous la moitié des personnes sur
cette photo sont mortes pour qu'on
découvre ce qui est à l'origine de tout
ça
vous fait pour sortir vivantes ces
jeunes
on n'en sort pas vivant
je t'arrête racan tous les joueurs sont
en or c'est ton tour
je vais choisir laquelle de vous deux
vêtues
action ou vérité